hi guys I'm Greg I'm Anita County good
aldo gems themself sent this video over
to me so you got it Aldo we're gonna
watch this Anita has never seen a weird
trailer I haven't seen a weird trailer
now weird trailers are very strange
are they weird they contain a lot of
random inserts okay this one seems like
it's going to be more specific though
lying there Norma
yeah normal trailer baby that's really
the actual reupload this one seems like
you're gonna be throwing in some Eddie
Murphy in this one they saw the entire
title here after year we did a rack a
rack of one he didn't know who they were
it's my turn it's your turn my turn
great and like I said this one's
probably be more specifically tuned time
but do it please like share subscribe
remove adblock in my favor
I took science there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
walk away the best thing that ever show
me the girl
[Music]
[Music]
Irving right you are doing any died a
lot every time to tell you this I'm not
gonna donate I'm not gonna donate my
donation me watching when you ask me
he's donating his time you know wow that
was really funny that was so fun to help
so many Eddie Murphy restaurant somehow
to really map that [ __ ] oh yeah
definitely that have to find so many
like right Eddie Murphy line how to go
here and there that was really really
good Jonathan a great detail was the one
where they had like the drawing of a
Murphy come back coming to America
normally it's just a bunch of randomness
yeah like it's very so weird
really you get the depression the how
does like really bake or something that
was very formulated yeah exactly yeah
that was actually formulated very
well-liked and all the red boxes and
everything seemed very specific right
when he's on a time yes sir yes so I was
impressed with that I thought it flowed
very well I thought it was really cool I
mean I thought it was amazingly funny
movie yes so might be a trunk from a
Murphy so Oh My yes tell me references
in there me has a great sense my
favorite Eddie Murphy with movies are 48
hours and Bowfinger I actually really
liked oh I forgot the name of it the one
where he's in prison with Martin
Lawrence and they run there for years
I didn't see those awful arias - I
really like that it's coming to America
coño America
ah try to cure anybody yeah
rocky told away that's what I want to do
a comedy character like wait a minute
that's Eddie Murphy dr. Steinberg hmm
make you want to watch the many Murphy
film me no actually I was mind doing
marathon we should be I'm here for no
reason why an Eddie Murphy marathon I
still live stream about that part where
he was like you read all these books
like I like when the beat coming to the
light him and suddenly it was like the
laughing anymore but it was a Bowfinger
one yeah I like to be intimate with the
classic Eddie Murphy laughs yeah I can't
do wait all right I'll dojo Jenner to
get you know again this is Alda looks a
lot like that animation though yeah a
little on that he's like this kind of V
song yeah he's like a bigger dude like
long-haired a huge beer night if you
telling her something I do yeah I do
guys now I thought he was like some
skinny eight-year-old look at your like
oh maybe give me that but then when you
come here like yeah yeah I realize that
how is it yeah subscribe to Aldo Jones
drinking this video at the top of the
description of this bog subscribe to the
real reject that's your second tab this
is real Thursday
God do I need a stargazers channel it's
a really fun challenge from peeing don't
be humble I'm not even I'm just being
honest crazy just kind of no kyani
photos on his inside yeah I guess
there's all kind of oh you get naked all
to much yeah
and I'm remembering the photos real
you're holding the camera
yeah how am I supposed to get the cool
and light from right nothing great I
hope you at the beach in the bad girl
I mean there's their band in half the
country yeah
if you take itself to cave that pole in
either why do you want to find the only
hold on to - Oh beautiful
does he ever just have gelatine is all
about good venture